were you a hundred percent work from the
office before
the pandemic were you eighty percent
where were you and then how do you think
about it as the ceo of a
do you said a thousand person company
how do you think about it because you're
listening now opinion
i um they are um
mostly we worked from an office yeah and
i've had time to reflect on how much of
that was
my own ego the feeling that i got when i
walked into the office and seeing
everyone working hard and
feeling the buzz of the culture how
important was that
to me one of the reasons that i got
involved with startups
almost right out of college was because
there was this huge hole in my life i
missed the dorm
i missed the sense of purpose that i had
as an idealistic college student
and i found it again in working 24
7 with other entrepreneurial people
first to build plum tree software
and later to build redfin and so i
really wanted us
to all be together and i still think
that there is a living death
doing one zoom after another um
i sometimes feel like a zombie but i
also know
that cracking the whip and just making
people come in when they have to commute
70 or 80 minutes to get to the office it
ain't worth it
and what you have because of a housing
crisis every employer is going through
this
is people say especially when they work
at a housing company like redfin
i'm a software engineer i'm a highly
paid professional
and yet i still don't make enough to buy
a house in one of the core
parts of the city and when they say what
i'm going to do
is work remotely you don't have to give
me a raise i'm moving to nebraska and
suddenly my wife can actually stop
working or my husband can stop working
because
one income is going to be enough to pay
the bills on a 250 000
house all you feel is relief you don't
try to tackle them
and say you've got to stay in seattle
you feel relieved
and our challenge had been that we have
a san francisco office and a seattle
office
and we always wanted people to move to
the san francisco office because
the home office with seattle was easier
for us to recruit there and so some
people would want to do that especially
younger folks san francisco is so
beautiful
but then when they went down there even
though we were offering to pay them 50
or 60 percent more they'd say it's not
worth it because they tour homes over
the weekend and say
i'm not going to move into that shoe box
so
we have had you know a slow migration in
america had has slow migration
out of these major urban centers for a
long time
the pandemic was just the straw that
broke the camel's back
um people have been leaving california
for five years before
it feels to massively pandemic yes
massive accelerant because
we were already having this conversation
and employees come to us and say hey
can i stay where i am i'm like a top
tier employee i might leave if you don't
it was like this negotiation
now it's like the balance of power i
don't know if you saw apple folded
netflix folded everybody's basically
folded and just said you know what okay
do what you want
as long as the ball keeps moving forward
what have we lost
because some of the things in coming to
an office uh
you know the esprit de corpse and the
and the energy
was palatable so for everything that is
gained
getting rid of the commute um all of
that seems amazing and i think it's
probably
i don't know what percentage great and
upside but what is lost and then what
percentage
is you know in this trade-off in your
mind is it 80
good 20 downside or all upside what do
you think
um i think it's on balance
good it's definitely on balance good for
the employee especially if you have a
family i think it hurts
new hires who are just trying to
learn the lay of the land especially if
you're younger and you don't already
have a network of friends and family in
town
there was this time when work especially
at a startup was almost like going to a
church that people
met their friends that way they met
their spouse that way they got their
sense of purpose in life
from that office and now
it's all being mediated through this
screen
and that is definitely a downgrade
yeah yeah so i think in general
work has become less important for
americans and what's been hard for me is
that
i was never the smartest entrepreneur in
the world
i was just the hardest working one so
somebody else would figure something out
in 30 minutes but i was willing to be
there all night
to grind it out and if you develop that
blue collar
ethic generally across the company that
we're just going to have to work a
little harder to deliver more value for
our customers
it doesn't quite square with the labor
shortage that we now have
the remote work liberation that we've
all gone through
i have lunch with my kids and i am still
a driven nut job i work all the time you
are asking me about my vacation
and it's just this anxiety that i'm not
a good enough ceo to slack off
so i need to figure that out and i think
silicon valley i need to figure
that same thing out yeah but so tell me
where you are in this because
it there is also you and i are both gen
xers
yeah we were raised with like well maybe
we could take over the system
and we could be in charge and we could
start our own things and now this seems
like this other generation was like
why would you want to give that up when
you could become a freelancer and take
six months off
and yolo go to coachella both weekends
and and we're trying to manage
a workforce that now is disconnected
from what we wanted from our lives they
want something
different it seems work-life balance i
guess is how most people say it so
do you think it's generational because
that's kind of my thought here is
like when i hear work-life balance i'm
like i'm sorry i don't understand
you know jason what you're talking about
i love what i do why would i want
balance i love this well have you ever
read
i know this is a bizarre reference but
there was this i think 10th or 11th
century
monk the venerable beat and
i remember reading him in college he
said that
the monks now and you know 10
50 are so much worse than the monks in
10 30.
and i was like oh please all of you were
very religious and very devoted and so i
try to avoid the crankiness that one
generation is lazy and another
generation isn't but i do think that
i do think that for me um
i've needed a calling that in between
plum tree and redfin plum tree went
public i made plenty of money i could
have gone anywhere in the world and
learned kite surfing or
sat in a beach in costa rica and what i
really wanted to do was to make a
difference in my life you referenced at
the beginning of the show that i had
this crisis of conscience where i almost
became a doctor which would have been
the worst thing that could have ever
happened to me because it is so
rules driven and narrow in some ways and
so good in other ways but
i just had to be free and creative but i
still had to figure out a way that i
could make a difference
and i'm not sure that speaks to everyone
in the same way
you know some people feel that in
joining a company
and signing up for a mission they're
just
giving up their freedom and so there's
always going to be that group of folks
who want
more degrees of freedom who want less
meaning out of their work
and just more time to spend on their
hobbies
and then i think they're going to be
those special little freaks who i still
want to gather around me who really want
to change the world
and are willing to put their shoulder to
the wheel
and work together with other folks to do
that and and
i don't know how else to change the
world i don't think you can just do it
by yourself
four hours a day contracting and dialing
in
teams today need a central hub for their
information and work
more than ever especially in a world of
remote work that's where notion comes in
it's one place for notes
docs projects and everyday work that
goes way beyond a wiki
when we went fully remote back in march
of 2020 when the pandemic started
notion became our internal knowledge
bank here is one of my producers going
through our pod notes page on notion
where we highlight the top lessons in
every episode
and it makes it really easy for us to
edit these get up and running and share
that knowledge
notion is the one place where every team
from engineering to
sales can work together seamlessly with
500 integrated apps
including of course google and slack
collaborate in real time
and tailor workflows to your needs
hundreds of
thousands of teams worldwide are already
delighting their employees with notion
notion has a worldwide community of
millions of users creating templates and
tutorials
so the product is continuously improving
now
every part of our group from the
investment side diligence when we do an
investment to the podcast booking guests
and pre-production plus post production
and marketing all done with checklist we
keep them on notion to make sure
everything gets done and they got
comments on notion it's such a great
product
go to notion.so and use the promo code
twist to get 250
off the annual team plan that's
incredibly generous
that's a couple of months free actually
for your growing team so go ahead and go
to notion.so and use the promo code
twist
at checkout for 250 off nicely done
notion okay
let's get back to this amazing episode